Resuelve la proporción.
8 entre 36 es igual a 10 ¿entre cuánto?
o bien, 8 entre 36
es igual a 10
¿a cuánto?
Hay varias formas de resolver este problema,
vamos a ver 4 de ellas.
La que te guste más, esa la puedes utilizar
para resolver este tipo de problemas.
Entonces, la primera dice lo siguiente,
vamos a fijarnos,
¿en cuánto se tuvo que multiplicar el numerador
para pasar de ser 8 a ser 10?
Como son fracciones equivalentes,
el denominador también se tuvo que
haber multiplicado por eso mismo.
Bueno, si empezamos con 8
y llegamos a 10,
pudimos haber multiplicado
por 10 entre 8, verdad...
lo voy a poner por acá,
si hacemos 8 por
1 0 entre 8 definitivamente llegamos a 10.
Entonces estamos multiplicando
por 10 entre 8,
pero 10 entre 8
es exactamente lo mismo
que 5 entre 4,
simplemente simplificamos,
10 entre 2 es 5, 8 entre 2 es 4.
Entonces estamos multiplicando
el numerador
por 5/4,
así para obtener
una expresión equivalente
el denominador
también lo tenemos
que multiplicar
por 5/4
y eso nos da una forma
de encontrar el valor de "n".
"n"
es igual a 36
multiplicado por 5,
por 5/4.
Y aquí podemos efectuar las operaciones,
esto de aquí es igual a 36
por 5 dividido
entre 4,
36 entre 4 es 9
y 9 por 5 es 45,
así que ésta es una forma de obtener
que el valor de "n"
es igual a 45.
Una segunda forma es la siguiente,
ahora podemos
fijarnos en cuanto se tuvo que multiplicar
este numerador
para llegar
a este denominador
y ahí tendría que multiplicarse
por 36 entre 8...
por 36
entre 8
y notemos que 36 entre 8
es lo mismo que...
vamos a simplificarlo dividiendo el numerador
y el denominador entre 4,
36 entre 4 es 9
y 8 entre 4 es 2,
entonces el numerador
se multiplicó por 9/2...
por 9/2
para llegar al denominador.
Así que aquí también debemos de multiplicar
el numerador por 9/2
para realmente tener una fracción equivalente,
sale...
entonces deja lo pongo
por acá en algún lado...
multipliqué 8...
8 por 9/2...
9/2 para llegar a 36,
así que ahora debo multiplicar 10...
10 por 9/2...
por 9/2
para llegar a "n".
Bueno, aquí nos quedaría 10 por 9
dividido entre 2...
entre 2,
10 entre 2 es 5
y 5 por 9 es 45,
así que esa es otra forma de obtener
que "n" es igual a 45.
Muy bien,
otra forma de resolver
este problema es multiplicar cruzado,
ahorita te digo
qué quiere decir multiplicar cruzado,
primero déjame decirte
que a mi no me gusta mucho,
porque es una cosa muy algorítmica, es decir,
es un procedimiento
que aveces no explican
porque funciona,
pero bueno,
vamos a ver en que consiste.
Multiplicar cruzado es lo siguiente,
si tenemos 2 fracciones iguales...
déjame poner aquí las fracciones otra vez...
voy a ponerle 8 entre 36...
8 entre 36
Ces igual a 10 entre "n"...
10 entre "n", ok.
Entonces si tenemos
dos fracciones iguales
podemos multiplicar este numerador
con este denominador
y eso va a ser igual a este numerador
por este denominador...
lo voy a hacer con colores...
este numerador por este denominador,
o sea "8n"
es igual a este numerador
por este denominador,
o sea, a 36
por 10.
Déjame realizar aquí algunas operaciones,
entonces tenemos que "8n"
es igual a 36 por 10,
o sea 360,
Esto parece un poco como magia,
pero en realidad
está justificado en algo de álgebra
que ahorita vamos a ver.
Entonces vamos a seguir con este procedimiento.
Imagínate que ya sabemos que "8n"
es igual a 360,
entonces,
¿cuál tendría que ser el valor de "n"?
¿por cuánto tenemos que multiplicar 8
para llegar a 360?
Bueno, pues podemos dividir ambos lados de
esta igualdad entre 8,
si ésta es una igualdad,
le tenemos que hacer lo mismo a ambos lados para que se preserve la igualdad, entonces
si aquí dividido entre 8, aquí también
tengo que dividir entre 8...
"8n" entre 8,
me queda simplemente "n"
y de
esta forma "n"
es igual a 360 entre 8.
Este argumento es un poco algebraico,
pero pudimos haberlo hecho de otra forma,
nosotros queríamos encontrar, 8 por cuánto
era igual a 360,
bueno, pues definitivamente
8 por 360 entre 8
es igual a 360,
verdad,
entonces este
numerito "n" debe de ser 360 entre 8.
Vamos a ver eso cuánto es
realizando la división de casita.
Entonces lo voy a hacer por aquí,
360 dividido entre 8,
8 cabe en 36 cuatro veces,
4 por 8 es 32,
aquí restamos, 36 menos 32 es 4,
baja el 0,
5 por 8 es exactamente 40,
aquí le pongo 5,
5 por 8 es 40, restamos
y no queda
residuo.
Entonces una vez más nos queda
que el valor de "n"
es igual a 45.
Y vamos a la última forma de resolverlo,
la última forma utiliza un poco de álgebra,
así que a lo mejor
los argumentos te parezcan
un poco extraños porque estamos
en la lista de reproducción de proporciones,
pero bueno,
es padre que te lo cuente porque así vas
a poder entender un poco mejor de donde sale
esto de la multiplicación cruzada,
de...
de eso...
multiplicar cruzado.
Bueno,
si no entiendes o se te hace un poco
extraño no te preocupes,
cuando aprendas un poco más de álgebra
le vas a entender mejor,
pero vamos a hacerlo.
Entonces la proporción que tenemos
es 8 entre
36...
8 entre 36
es igual
a 10 entre "n",
lo que vamos a hacer aquí
es despejar "n"
y para despejar "n",
conviene que quede en el numerador,
así que voy a empezar
multiplicando por "n"
ambos lados de esta igualdad,
si multiplico
por "n" de un lado,
debo multiplicar por "n" del otro
para que se preserve la igualdad,
aquí esta "n" se cancela
con esta "n"
y me queda que 8 entre 36
multiplicado por "n"...
8 entre 36 multiplicado por "n"
es igual a
10...
igual a 10.
Y ahora debo despejar "n",
así que debo deshacerme de este término
y para eso voy a multiplicar por 36 ,
entre 8,
si multiplico por 36 entre 8
del lado izquierdo,
también debo de multiplicar por
36 entre 8 del lado derecho,
para preservar la igualdad,
aquí a la izquierda
36 se cancela con 36,
8 con 8
y me queda simplemente que "n"...
"n" es igual a 10 por 36 entre 8,
o sea, a 36
por 10
dividido entre 8.
Y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que obtuvimos aquí a la izquierda,
simplemente 36 por 10 es 360,
entonces "n" es igual
a 360 dividido entre 8
y esto ayuda a entender mucho mejor
de donde viene la multiplicación cruzada.
La "n" la pasamos multiplicando,
pero eso realmente
es multiplicar por "n" de ambos
el 36 también lo pasamos multiplicando,
pero eso fue lo que hicimos aquí,
cuando multiplicamos
por 36 en el numerador
de este lado y de este lado.
Y luego el 8 aquí lo pasamos dividiendo,
dividimos entre 8 de ambos lados
que fue este entre 8
que quedó aquí,
aquí entre 8 y
aquí entre 8.
Bueno, entonces "n" también
nos queda 360 entre 8,
de modo que "n"
una vez más es igual a 45.
Bueno, aquí tienes 4 formas
de resolver un mismo problema,
siempre nos quedó
que el valor de "n" es igual a 45
y bueno,
depende de cual prefieras
o cual se te haga más sencilla
para que utilices
esa en tus problemas,
creo que las más sencillas
son ver en cuanto cambio el numerador
y utilizar la técnica
de multiplicación cruzada.